this is a good opportunity let's talk
about the next segment do it this
YouTube CEO users don't like
authoritative mainstream media but we
boost them anyway right the first thing
you have to do I have to like the video
hit the like button subscribe
notification bell and then share this I
think it's no it's gonna get good I got
some I'm gonna I'm gonna drag some of
these lefty journalists who are angry
that people can share YouTube links it's
amazing I know because they can't
control the narrative right okay okay
this is nuts check it out we know this
we know that nobody likes these videos
listen look up CNN or any one of these
you know CBS or Fox or whatever their
videos are boring nobody wants to watch
them they all have thumbs down and they
get like 10,000 views if that and then
you go to like my channel type my videos
got like 300 4000 views and I'm like
people are choosing my content when
presented they're not choosing CBS ABC
NBC etc but because YouTube is propping
these channels up they're getting
hundreds of millions of views you know
much money that is now bonkers lots of
money lots and lots of money let me let
me think real quick let's see I think
CNN is probably getting probably a
million bucks a month low estimate from
YouTube alone because and that's and
that's off taking clips from their shows
and just uploading without question
without even trying to engage with
YouTube and because YouTube is putting
them up think about how much money
YouTube would actually make if they
chose to show real independent creators
that actually get the engagement they
don't care though because they're scared
of these media outlets they're scared of
people at BuzzFeed and yes I'll give
Ryan Broderick the credit they're scared
of people like Ryan Broderick this dude
who I'm not sure if I've ever met him
but he really has this thing for no
matter what happens he's got to call it
a problem okay check us out you may have
seen planned emic I'm at a big fan I'm
not I'm not a big fan because I think
it's an interview with one person who
may or may not be correct I understand
she's a doctor so I could only defer to
the X
but there's there's there's a lot of
things that could have done better and
you know hey it is what it is but
YouTube shouldn't different have removed
it because they took away any
opportunity for debate and challenging
of the idea
it's a stupidest nick had done yeah
check us out in let me show you the
Casey Newton tweet first he says I wrote
about how planned emic went viral
facebook groups linking to YouTube
driving tremendous attention in a short
amount of time and okay that's just
literally the internet yeah what's your
issue well welcome to the Internet Ryan
says YouTube knows this is a problem in
April I reached out about the absurd
traffic that YouTube videos were getting
on Facebook particularly in groups they
told me the video is not recommended by
our systems the majority of the traffic
and views come from external sites a
problem Wow
what problem that someone can share a
link last May last year YouTube changed
the algorithm to strike down channels
like mine it used to be that if you
watched one of my videos the autoplay
recommendation would show you more of my
videos so all of these these these I'll
do air quotes activist come activists
got angry
oh no we're so angry because people with
opinions we don't like our getting
traffic and you know we work for
BuzzFeed so YouTube changes the
algorithm okay here's what I did I
started saying at the beginning of all
my videos if you want to support my work
the best thing you can do is share this
video because the YouTube algorithm is
weighted against me but there's nothing
more powerful than a direct share we can
go ahead and take this time to say go
ahead and share this video share this
video and tell everyone how awesome we
are baby please continue Tim but in all
seriousness look at look at what he's
saying this is a guy from BuzzFeed he
writes these hit pieces he's been wrong
on several occasions and he's literally
angry right now that people on Facebook
have shared links what's the alternative
let's say YouTube says okay we've
decided we're going to outright ban
everybody what's so that YouTube just
becomes Netflix shows the only people
who can post are is Netflix think about
what he's saying right here YouTube
knows this is a problem what that users
can upload videos and share the link
what does you think that what YouTube's
for literally literally what it's
supposed to be
but here you it's unsurprising that this
is what you know BuzzFeed focuses on he
was gonna say since the pandemic started
I've written several stories focusing on
the X the explosion of Facebook users
sharing YouTube links what excuse me
this is literal agen how it used to be
when when YouTube first started people
would go on Facebook and they would
share links Facebook got mad because it
was driving traffic off of their site so
Facebook started reducing the amount
that YouTube links would appear right
it's countered now because people make
groups and so when you're in a group the
post appears two people in the group
he's mad he's mad about it haha short
thread YouTube's attempts to clean up
their platform have not stopped and may
even attempts to claim the land and may
even be exacerbating the Facebook
exacerbating the Facebook sharing the
search results for covet content are
cleaned up but on Facebook things are
complete free for all and we can't
control it what do we do relieving our
power people on the Internet are talking
Oh No is this if Ian holy cow this is
amazing this second largely unmoderated
YouTube on moderated YouTube via
Facebook is especially bad in India
where some of the most-watched kovat 19
videos in the world are in Hindi and
full of misinformation I don't disagree
that disinformation is bad right it's a
very big problem but guess what
what's what's let me ask you what do you
do if like you know Billy Bob walks down
to the local watering hole and says hey
man I heard that this thing was
orchestrated and the other guy goes Wow
are you gonna show up and be like stop
talking are you gonna write a newspaper
article dangerous things are happening
where people are talking apparently you
are whispers sharing thoughts and ideas
oh no I see someone at bud speeds and
it's full of misinformation and then I
know what I know because I've been in
this world now seeing the mainstream
media spreading misinformation yeah like
I'm on Twitter now and I follow people
on both sides of the spectrum as far as
like politicals and it's like both sides
are just spouting misinformation that
just proves their own points you know
and this happens but why cyber ones to
be correct
yeah and then it switches but it doesn't
switch yeah you're right it does it's
mostly on the right yeah it's it's like
this well I mean there are some
environmental things that people on the
left are saying that is from truth but
that's but that's you know that's not an
issue of reality that's ocean of opinion
right okay well that's what I'm talking
about though zone of things so you can
say something like I do not like Donald
Trump removing environmental protections
right that was one of my things and then
a conservator will say I do like it's
good for business and you'll say it's I
don't think so I think it's bad for
everybody ball blog it's an argument
that's right
okay but three four or five years of
Russia you know your justice Millette
Covington you hold really high-profile
examples of how the media just gets
everything wrong no i 100% agree that
it's mostly a one-sided thing
so these way to explain it is you do
have fake news on the right the 5g
conspiracy stuff it's like it's not fair
to call that right-wing to be I was
gonna say isn't that just like random
nuts everywhere right because you know
anyone Karen artisan Karen on Facebook
yeah Karen on Facebook saying something
like you know the towers are coming for
us is not exclude it's not it's nothing
to do with the right right I mean or
left and yeah and and and there are a
lot of left-wing crazy conspiracy
theories and recently Chris Hayes of
MSNBC in an interview said they're
they're out of their gourds why not
so conspiracies happen but I'll tell you
what I can't give you the exact number
but it's something like this
six out of ten stories that come from
the right are correct four out of ten
stories that come from the left are
correct okay and so if you're on the
left you have a tendency to be wrong if
you're on the right you've tendency to
be right okay but I'm not saying
political right or left I'm saying
culture war right and left and that's
because a lot of moderate and
independents are now somehow aligned
with the right simply because there's
issues of freedom and free speech and
free thought you know you look at like
ben shapiro
who's like the joke about ben shapiro is
debate me you know i mean yeah like he
wants to have the ideas challenged he
wants down yeah and the left is shut him
down cancel their show Cantor speech
yeah we don't want to debate we don't
want to get in an opportunity where you
can just prove us wrong exactly and so
that creates a dynamic and that's
exactly what we're seeing right now with
BuzzFeed
yeah okay let's read a little through a
little bit more he says increasing
facebook traffic for YouTube videos has
also
mirrored the rise in conspiracy theories
the 5g truth or Facebook groups are full
of YouTube links that they share with
each other because the videos look more
legitimate than native Facebook content
that's definitely true about whether it
looks good or not Facebook kind of is
garbage yeah and the video that I got
YouTube to comment on was the one that
claimed after foul she is a member of
the deep state the video is viewed over
6 million times its biggest referrals
were aqune on Facebook group a Christian
mommy bloggers page and a chiropractor
random the Deep States is a specific
colloquial reference to permanent to
members of what they call the permanent
government and this is actually what
what someone in the intelligence
community called it these are people who
are holdovers right you know so george w
bush albick i'm gonna appoint this guy
to the FBI and then obama comes in and
the guy stays you know and then trump
comes in and the guy stays that's what
people refer to as deep state people who
have who have been in government and
aren't elected were appointed and just
stay oh aren't elected right ok so if
someone said doctor foul she's a member
of the deep state I'm like that's just a
colloquial way to explain that doctor
foul she has been in government in this
position for decades yeah that he wasn't
elected he wasn't changed and that's a
big aspect of our government yeah it's
not sinister yeah right but you know
look because conspiracy theorists might
use similar terminology it's like oh
yeah YouTube knows Facebook users are
sharing YouTube videos at a higher rate
and you can see the traffic increase on
social metrics sites like buzzsumo and
crowd tangle which means Facebook knows
this too but each platform is expecting
the other one to moderate this it's a
mess what do you want to happen on the
internet with the Internet I don't know
we must shut early founding Facebook is
like it's a youtube link where do we
split you so Facebook already censors a
lot of content you know YouTube already
took down ton of tons of these videos
you know what's gonna happen
someone's gonna pose it to live leak or
bit shoot and then they'll post it to
Facebook yeah you can't stop this it's a
core function of what the internet is
yeah
hey sorry we're connected in the
Internet you can't stop us we're gonna
stay connected now imagine when are they
gonna get that it feels like they want
to go back to like the 90s kind of you
know when people were just like oh
what's the internet dial-up
what's that haha but I'm gonna go read
the newspaper I think I think it's more
in line with Trump derangement syndrome
okay like so outside of what Trump
derangement syndrome is focused on Trump
there's a general effect so people who
no matter what it is it's always wrong
it's always bad it must be stopped so at
first they're like you know Alex Jones
is on YouTube and he's saying things we
disagree with then YouTube gets rid of
him yeah okay well we still have to be
mad about something so people are
sharing links on Facebook yeah that's
crazy
no Wow someone shared a link BuzzFeed
how do you think you make money what did
question 10 people take the links well I
don't make money from me that's for sure
I don't go to BuzzFeed websites like
BuzzFeed like Vox like Mike calm which
is like mostly defunct got started by
manipulating Facebook's algorithm okay
because people would share the stories
so there's we've had ones before one of
the some of these sites have used to be
like right-wing libertarian mmm-hmm
because you know police brutality videos
were very very popular for a long time
yeah so the the approach was if you were
all about Liberty you could play to the
left and the right okay because every
like most Americans detest racism so you
know wasn't a left or right issue so all
of these sites first started out kind of
like on a libertarian event when they
started figuring out that it's older
women who share the most so the content
slowly started skewing towards new moms
you want me to say it what Karen's yes
parents yes you're thinking it to Karen
yeah that's absolutely it yeah and so
then more shares more money mm-hmm so
they started hiring people to write
these things and thus we got the wave of
critical race Theory social justice
stuff because Facebook was being
exploited here's the funny thing
that I complain about people's ability
to share links I think it's a serious
problem that Facebook drove this but
that he is it's like imagine a zombie
complaining about zombies like you have
come you have complained about YouTube
quite often in on our show yeah but
that's not for right right reasons I've
defended YouTube against the lies that
YouTube radicalizes people it's not true
okay I've complained about YouTube
censoring in favor of these people yes
well and pushing CNN and exactly
squashing
you down right no I'm not saying you're
not justified I'm not I'm not talking
about them complaining about their
problem I'm talking about
they were propped up and now they're mad
other people are taking advantage of the
same system buzzfeed was propped up for
a while yes they made on they
manipulated the Facebook algorithm well
okay I should say sites like a BuzzFeed
huffington post and this is what they
were doing he's mad
or I should say he's the remnant of oh
no we're being displaced the system we
were exploiting is taking away from us
right that's what it sounds like now
when but you could argue there's some
overlap between my complaints with
YouTube propping up mainstream media
mm-hmm but it's kind of an inversion
right CNN doesn't produce content that
people actually want to see and engage
with and they actually produce lies yeah
so he's arguing that people are
producing fake news it's like bro this
guy's written several fake stories and
got called out for this guy yeah this
guy specifically vide writing it just
sounds like he's just crying about it so
it's like this whole zombie system they
function on was pushing shock content
that was outrage and generate shares
I've explained this before YouTube
doesn't generate shares the way Facebook
does on Facebook when a link pops up and
it says you know dog does backflip yeah
people click share and all of a sudden
that pops up in the feeds of all their
friends mm-hmm YouTube doesn't have that
function you know if you click so you
can like a video and then if people go
to your YouTube you know page they may
like it but nobody does that yeah no one
does that so maybe I don't know some
people might do it Facebook so I'll
clarify there is a slight possibility of
radicalization through YouTube but it's
I would argue that it's relatively
negligible okay
more so than without YouTube but not
noticeable because there was there been
several studies showing that on YouTube
you have to choose what you watch yeah
Facebook is different Facebook you get
like three posts you can see on your
monitor right and so when people go on
and they see a video of a cop beating
somebody they click share all of us and
everyone just sees it whether they've
chosen it or not so that allows these
this radicalization to propagate
extremely rapidly then these these
companies that have made money off
exploiting the system gets scared
that people like me on YouTube call them
out so they accuse us of what they do
yeah it's what it's it's projection and
it's you know the problem is hmm when
you get people like me that are willing
to be honest about it and not lyin sheet
where a severe disadvantage because
BuzzFeed lies all the time they make up
fake news but because they have venture
capital and institutional power they can
write fake news about me and then all of
a sudden I get all of these they circle
the wagons are on each other
they defend their venture capital
interests no none of these people want
to lose money so we are the bigger
threat because we're independent
individuals taking their views away
going up against the machine yeah so the
machine will prep itself and then and
they do it to everybody and the the the
the funniest example I guess is the
President of the United States someone
who is sure that one of the most
powerful people in the world you know
but they do to him too because it's the
same thing he wasn't supposed to be you
know president he's basically taken the
power so they're panicking and trying to
stop him and crush him in any way
possible they are circling the wagons
you know that's named the game man Wow
you know it's really funny about
BuzzFeed Ben Smith I don't care well the
editor-in-chief of BuzzFeed news uh-huh
when and Busbee was coming all this
crazy crap mm-hmm and I'm like man cuz
I've known Ben for a little while it's
like I've known him very well and I'm
like why is this happening like I
thought Ben was better than this
yeah then quits he goes to New York
Times huh and now he's writing some of
the best stuff ever ever trying out Joe
Biden yeah yes he couldn't stand what's
going on baby maybe he had a mandate
yeah yeah but now he's at the New York
Times
you still laude what right but he's not
like you'd think even the New York Times
would be more compromised but he's got
presumably more freedom that's like it
yeah well that name Ben Smith Ben Smith
oh yeah and it's like finally some of
the New York Times now calling out a lot
of what we all see nice and it's great
like notably he called out the Joe Biden
defense from the New York Times yeah
like we questioned it okay he also
called out CNN for faking the Chris
Cuomo quarantine thing and I was like
wow yes Bravo and I tweeted this too and
this is this is a this is big for me I
was like I
almost forgot what real journalism
looked like I know hate and then you
know he's like hey CNN he said CNN was a
lighting the the Cuomo controversy
because Cuomo comes out of his basement
like look I'm not quarantined anymore it
is so stupid you were caught you were
caught like thirty minutes from your
house bro yeah but he tweeted about it
and I was like wow that's great New York
Times cuz they got a lot of bad people
over there man
yeah but near Times is is not the worst
I'd give them like a six out of ten and
they do a lot of good factual reporting
like they're one of the best the AP I
think is the best okay ah the AP and PBS
do a really really good job the problem
the New York Times is that editorially
they aren't in the bag for Democrats
that means when when critical political
stories pop up you can't trust what they
write when certain tech stories pop up
you can a little bit but they're also
extremely biased against Google because
they think they deserve Google's money
they're like Google has displaced News
therefore Google should pay us there's
actually in I think I'm not sure if it's
in France or whatever there's a suit
where there's there's an issue Google
crawls on a new story right okay and
then if you google search there will be
a box that appears that gives you the
gist of the news story so what happens
is the New York Times will write a story
Google will take the information and it
will appear on Google com
hmm where they sell ads of course and
then when you see that you're like wow
Donnell jump to the backflip moving on
whereas in the past you had to go to the
New York Times to get the news Google is
infringing on their market yeah so you
got to be careful about those biases but
you know there we go at the same time
you know Facebook is training its AI to
censor hateful memes yeah yeah yeah you
know man here you my needs I think I
said this 10 about ten years ago ten
years ago we were in like the John
Dillinger era of bank robbers okay you
know was like the bank robberies happen
all over the place and the gangsters
were there and they were alike
anti-heroes almost some of them were
really villains and we had all these
hackers doing this hacker stuff and I
was like this is that age because
they're gonna lock this down
everything's gonna become rigid and
authoritarian and we can see it
happening in real time so my prediction
would be in ten years there's gonna be
like three websites okay
um and you're gonna have your page like
you know like your your information for
your website would be a Facebook page
Facebook Amazon and Google yep mm-hmm
well what would Google do give you any
information you ask it people are gonna
have all their information on some
social profile no they're gonna have
neuro-link what's the newest times this
I already know the answer boner link
yeah but I'm talking about websites and
how we interact with the Internet but
that's what I'm saying it won't be the
same we're gonna have like think what
knurling does and that's just the base
level imagine there's like 30 years
afterwards like we're gonna thinking in
some information what kind of
information do I need right now now I
know all the information it's like the
matrix how do I fly the helicopter now I
know how to fly it in 10 years I doubt
it well no no I'm not saying in 10 years
I'm saying once neural Licht becomes a
normal thing and then think 10 30 years
after that yeah you know I'm not
convinced the 10 or 15 years ago they
were talking about those RFID chips get
under your skin
yeah and people were getting them and
you they'd wave their hand of a door in
the door would open yeah and people
still don't get him mm-hmm it's like I
remember alex jones was like they're
getting the chips of our chips coming
and then it never did okay because you
got a phone yeah I go to my hotel I
wiggle my phone for the door the door
opens we don't need you know implants in
that capacity you know I think neural
link maybe but the issue is humans have
a really difficult time implanting
things and some people do it most people
won't do it did you know that you can
give yourself electro sense or whatever
it's called a electro perception I'm not
sure what its what's called it no it is
it you can take a neodymium magnet and
embed it in your fingertips okay and
then you can feel electrical waves very
interesting it gives you the ability to
detect electrical like EMF
electromagnetic field but for what
purpose though to stay away from its
entire stress sense bro you could put
your hand on a wall and feel where the
where the power cables are interesting
yeah makes me think it's like a platypus
or given up that color blind guy that
implanted this thing that he can smell
colors now whoa you ever see this oh he
actually has an implant that comes out
like a little
device that's connected to his brain and
he can like smell colors or something
wouldn't wouldn't you weird wouldn't you
want the ability to sense electro
electro electrical fields it's
interesting yeah I don't know so it
isn't interesting if you if you're if
you're looking to mount stuff in walls
or you're looking for where the line is
coming in you use hold your hand over
you're like oh there's a power cable and
then you know exactly where it is or you
can tell if a wire is live or not
you'll be like whoa that's that's live I
can't touch it yeah so a lot of people
have done these done that done this
because it's really cool you can feel
like you put your hand you're like wow
like it's it's a sense something you've
never experienced before huh I'm curious
as to what the perception is so the way
it works is that your fingertips are
very sensitive and so putting a magnet
under the skin when it's when it detects
when the magnet comes in contact with
the wave it starts called you know
putting pressure and vibrating a little
bit and it puts pressure on your nerve
mmm so what I've read and I've never
done it I know some people who have is
that it's not like touch it's something
different it's like you can feel
electricity it's weird and interesting
it so people know this they don't do it
so you said that most most people have a
problem with implants well what have you
seen that black mirror episode where
they have the contacts that record your
entire life and they can go back to any
and watch anything it's like wouldn't
that be like the computer of the future
then or the cell phone of the future
just that comes out no no because it's
hard not an implant
they just pop it in and like maíno's
they figure it out so that it allows the
oxygen to flow through so you don't have
to take it out you just leave it in and
you just have your cell phone is just in
your eyeball so so right now contact
lenses have the problem of permeability
right so that's why you take them out
yeah it exactly yeah so for those that
aren't familiar the oxygen off yeah
eyeball
for those that aren't familiar with
lenses the capillaries can grow over
your eyes because your eyes are
struggling to get oxygen to you know so
you need to breathe maybe they do maybe
odd thing but there's a way they can do
it that it's like bad it's like but you
know for now like I know talking about
the argument is in the future for now
it's like yeah we have to solve that
problem let's say we did I wonder if
it's still just a hassle yeah I got my
phone right here I know it looks really
funny like mine you know in Futurama
when you know Leela is wearing the rest
of a
with the screen on it okay you you yeah
yeah so uh and there's also a video game
called Commander Keen okay you know
Commander Keen he wore a wrist computer
as well sure I remember I was little I
was like man it's the future his
computer and that and then I got a phone
and I'm like no one is ever going to
puts on the wrist but that made no sense
think about what like a contact phone
would give you the ability to number one
you'd probably be able to just think you
can already already do in this where you
can think things and they're like text
comes up or whatever you tell it
whatever so if you had it in your in
your eyeball you can watch whatever you
want to watch you know it's just there's
one objects it anywhere to do them boom
3d virtual reality like you were saying
like man if neuro-link I just plug into
sup we're done working Skyrim boom and
you're playing Skyrim you know there's
no contacts that actually how would the
contacts Lee seeing how would the
contact saw great sense of touch
interact with your brain who knows so
the the neural link has very very fine
wires that they have to mount human hair
right so maybe in the future one of the
challenges rejection I'm sure Elon Musk
is smart enough to know this better than
I do so yeah you know I'll defer to him
sure but what do we do like when you're
one you when you're one they put the
neural link implant and you get like a
port on your neck and you can like plug
in a USB port or it could be Wireless
it's like a wire a Wi-Fi that's why I
thought I would assume Wi-Fi antennas
are tiny but what powers it
theoretically aren't we
electrical beings like don't we have I
mean couldn't we figure out a way that
we power it the radio waves themselves
might be able to give it enough power to
transmit signals because signals are
particularly weak relative to like an
actual attract device okay maybe it's
that simple
hmm you know but I don't know yeah who
knows we we've entertained the idea of
implants maybe the problem is their
their use factor wasn't enough like the
RFID chips opening a door who cares yeah
who cares it's not worth getting this
thing you know they this big needle they
put it in and then they deposit it was
silly but neural link would be
substantially more beneficial yeah you
know I think it might be mmm actually
they're they're talking about people who
have spinal injuries okay we might see
this start where some
who's paraplegic gets the implant and
then they get an electrode at the other
part of the spine after the break
nice so the signal can jump Wireless
uh-oh I never even thought and then they
great and then it sits and in the yield
they can get up and walk around like
normal doe will have to relearn probably
yeah but then the signal can travel
because we've created a you know this
jump a part of me thinks that he is
doing this because he's afraid of AI and
wants to figure out a way to make us
part of AI he said that oh yes I'm
pretty sure he said that I don't know if
you said exactly that I'm saying
what that he wants to make us part of a
it's good if we're integrated with it no
I know I know he's afraid of AI but it's
like neuro-link makes us that's hard I'm
pretty sure his argument oh cool yeah
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it's
what he said that I didn't see it
integrated with it there's no there's no
worker episode there's no Terminator
scenario but we are with the AR s1 if we
are there yep interesting yeah scary I
don't know man I mean I guess it would
kind of be good you're talking you know
you're you're talk in the early stages
you're at Thanksgiving with your family
and you've got that one really dumb
uncle or whatever okay and he's like I
don't know about that it's like Chuck
and he goes wow you were right yeah or
just like no arguments I were and that's
what the future of the internet is go
ahead and check there would still be
opinion though because eject I just
checked all that facts all the facts on
that what opinions wouldn't change based
on that because that's about you're
right you're right the opinions wouldn't
change right there would still be real
ideas out there well you're right that
Donald Trump did say that but I don't
think it's a big deal
and then they would argue what do you
mean don't think it's a big deal of
course the big weekend of perspective
yep yeah and that wouldn't change but at
least we'd have the facts together so
when you say something like Obama gate
and they go that's a debunked conspiracy
theory you're like no but look let's be
honest man we can pull up on our phones
yeah people still don't want to do it
that's true yeah you know they do a lot
when people like when I'm talking to
somebody and they're like argue with me
I'll just be like I'll just pull up on
my phone I don't say nothing and I'll
bet you go and they'll be like well I
don't know if I believe that I'm like I
don't care if you believe it or not
whatever I'm done sources don't work for
you then I don't the point of talking
you guys thanks for checking out this
clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you